Can you're a pretty cool guy yeah
You got tattoos. I got tattoos - that means you're cool. So cool, bro
Are you wearing a shirt so you can show off your tattoos? I mean I have a shirt on
Yeah, but my tattoo you can still see him
Don't you take it off for you, baby? I'll strip wait. I have an idea. Oh, let's look at bad tattoos
Don't you point at me?
How do you know oh, you can see me
Let's review some bad tattoos. Yay. My favorite I love making fun of other people's life choices
Literally my favorite thing to do is because you have some insecurities about your own
Number one number one some guy tried to copy my tattoos artists work and
tattooed a nipple on his arm
Text Wow
Give me this tattoo right here say no more fam nipple. He actually went back to touch
He wears me like dude, where's the frickin nipple? Yeah got the nipple you do boy
But it's not even a bad job. That's actually kind of a decent copy job
You know, you think that's a decent cut job colored. It's okay
You want me to do your next tattoo bro, if you think that's decent
Let me let me do your next at 10. Next exhale roses are red. My name's Dave. This poem makes no sense
microwave Oh
Goddamn it. Yeah
sick roms
Tasting that bad
He's a wedding having this guy in front of you at the airplane if you imagine like who was is like wife or his girlfriend
That somehow he has having this tattoo cuts his hair in this way
Yes, someone has to do it. Yeah, it someone has to keep that up
That's like what inside it haircut cold when you have really long in the back like a mole or a mullet. Yeah
mullet America second X
America's haircut, this is the level above that of the mall
So if you're on a plane, you know, you just just hopped in coach. You're sit behind this guy
What do you do? You know, he leans this chair back? It's like he's lunging at you. I could jump scared
I mean, it looks like he's flirting with me out. He's a girl
You start making out I
Learned that my friends Chinese tattooed literally means turkey sandwich, what do ii
I love turkey sandwiches. Yeah, what the hell? That's what he wanted. Why are you judging this?
I mean every tattoos got a story right like dude. What is your tattoo mean? He's just like
Gross
Doctors like hey, I could get that Garrett. I can get that off fray. Yeah
$120. Yeah, or I can get a tattoo but some Jordan on there dug it to my ear Oh
Allison you're in the Perino. Yes
You know, honestly this tattoo eat as small as it is probably hurt a lot
Yeah those dots on your nip
So, you know like you your nipple like it's not always hard, you know
I wonder what it looks like when it kind of relaxes a little bit right now. Yeah, it is ya know
I mean me I got me got me fat. I don't know your nips always hard 100%
Based they move around a little bit not open your body. Wait. Wait, this is our discussion to have
Please keep going. Have you ever?
Have you ever just like licked your finger they might touch the nip and just kind of it's smaller, you know
That's the tattoo also does the space get smaller?
Bra
What are the turtle Vinny why they call it didn't last it's just it's limited ads
It's still monetized because limited ads gives you nothing
And you still get something though. There's still an to play. No, that's like that's like
They take 90% of your earnings and it's like hey, look you still get something
You here you go ray. Yeah
Crashing my frickin thumbnail
Speaking of bad ads Ken are you thinking about buying a property? Why? Yes, I am consider buying a property
Oh, wow. Are you thinking about getting a mortgage to buy a property? Uh
Yeah, yeah my channel slowly dying. So I think I will have to take one out
maybe you should go to the bank get a mortgage and
buy a property if we talk about
Expensive things we will get better ads. Oh
Yes, I have thirteen
Dodge Chargers and now you're gonna buy 13 and I love tick tock videos
Videos good ads is that still thing? It didn't like tik-tok least. I put ads and everything you can get a ton of money
Yeah, I don't know that why everybody made kick top videos for so long
Dude, I resent that I make it because they're really funny and fun to watch
Oh and definitely like dodging all the music claims is not a pain in the ass. Yeah, they're definitely
Oh that that's not why I stopped
It's my life. Jon bovi. My my favorite my favorite musician it Oh Jon bovi
What is his name?
Bon Jovi
Well, the other part is it it's is my life oh god I didn't see it
Yeah
Oh
My lord almighty God
What on earth is that?
There's a Peter in his nose. Oh good get sure there's mr. Peters here
Take it away
Faraday's Barrett is the ultimate and my favorite
Oh, yes
Look my head looks like a I have a baby's body tattooed on my chest. I get all the ladies. Ah
It's supposed to be a galaxy this shibori and this is your brain on crack
Expect my face. Oh
No, that's
If it is real, it's pretty freakin good
Spray I'm pressing. Yeah, that looks legit some Ohio hands agrees. Yeah, heck. Yeah. Oh nice
Stars
Cool, so you got a bunch of dots on you some hair on her chest I'm saying
someone sprinkle pepper on
You know, sometimes you gotta add a little spice today
There we go god this stuff makes me uncomfortable
You are if you have titties don't ruin them, why would you do that? It's kind of good
It's really good. Look at look at shading on that face. It looks just like Eminem on them Eminem. I
Just spit some rhymes on you. Oh my god. I want to lie, and that looks like it's screaming in pain
I love Italy so much. Please give me this. Okay?
Here you go. Say no more
That's a Shrek ear
What the dots on his answer you got a unibrow vapor dark Wow
Look at the vape and it goes up into a wolf
Dude is like dude Streep
It's the flavor of freedom oh
Crap. Hello. Y'all call out to all you tattoo fans
I'm doing some awesome new tat charging on the pay what you can
Basis if you want to be awesome in a hero, look no further. The tad above is a spiral my own design. Wow
I
Can't wait for all them calls. I'm about to get here's my infected spiral that I did. Oh my
It's a little red first. It's a small tattoo. It's looks like very swollen and the line isn't even clean like it's not supposed to
Expand or leak like that? Yeah, that's pretty good
I also asked focuses on someone's shoulder or something but the size of those hairs. Is this somebody's foot
This is a super small like a little bitty tattoo on the side. Oh my god. It couldn't be you're right. Oh my god
this is like the
40 year old smoking lady
yeah, I wouldn't get a Playboy bunny right my hair but
It's always been a dream of mine
Let me go down to the trailer park and get Oh Frank, he's kind of good in the other day
He hooked me up and they gotta pay pay what you can prize. Oh, yeah, you did a mean foot tattoo the other day
I'm diggin. It was a spiral hot. This one didn't even get infected. Oh
Is that donna mater it is that Kyle. Oh, I can't tell you so small
That it's one good joke
I'm gonna buy it to to gun to make it that way that that dog. It's easiest see you do it all the time
My dead mother this is actually she looks like she dig her up right now. I
got it, so I wouldn't forget her but now I want to
At least I got the gap in her teeth, right, you know, oh those bras. Oh
Nice right by the fuse box Wow, go easy. Oh,
I've seen this one. It's pretty good. Oh, yeah. Yeah. This is a pretty good cover-up
Thick Jimmy. I got this super bad Pikachu tattoo. Now. Here's a drunk Pikachu draw on it
see, this is why you should go to a good tattoo artists and spend that extra dollar like I
Can get that $20.00 tattoo or spend 120 dollars per hour, you know, it's something that I'm not going to regret
Tattoos are
Awesome, and you should get one. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, and if anyone says there goes bad when you're old who cares you're gonna be old and looking bad. Anyway, that's right. Yeah
Just don't get it on your face or your hands because then you'll be unemployable check out
Ken, everyone what you never played super simulator?
You know, it's fun right I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not convinced yet. Okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is available for free and that's a great price